[Musique]
contre retour à l'heure de l'atlantique
en gaspésie ce que j'entends souvent le
des gens qui prônent le changement
horaire c'est qu'on va pouvoir prendre
via sa terrasse une heure plus tard mais
la contrepartie de cela c'est que nos
enfants qui vont prendre l'autobus
scolaire le matin
bonds est amorcée mais pour moi c'est
juste une question d'avoir plus de
lumière à la fin de la journée
[Musique]
phénomène naturel pour les êtres humains
de vouloir des marques et le temps selon
cet historien épuisant qui se levait à
l'abord du jour pu travailler jusqu'à la
noire ça mais avec la révolution
industrielle
on a rentré dans les quarts de travail
avec la révolution industrielle et
l'arrivée du très aînés le temps
universel coordonné l'heure de greenwich
c'est un monde est allé s'offrir fleming
qui va proposer en 1881 diffusé à la
haine différents qui commence à
greenwich la décision de faire des
fuseaux horaires est une décision
scientifique maintenant au moment de
l'application c'est autre chose
les états se sont effectivement ajusté
en fonction d'aléas historique
d'arrangements politiques et d'enjeux
économiques
pointe-à-la-croix en gaspésie la
frontière du nouveau-brunswick
même si on est au carrefour de côté de
chemin la réserve de des stigmates
soldats de l'otan six autres joueurs
avancés et lorsqu'on traverse ce front
là aussi à ce moment alors on saute on
se trouve sur encore sur le banc l'heure
de l'atlantique
aken halte-là kempen et lorsqu'on
revient à pointe-à-la-croix mais là on
est sur l'air du québec monsieur
goudreau comme d'autres citoyens de
pointe-à-la-croix a décidé de vivre
alors de l'atlantique
quoi qu'il en soit pour oublier de
change dollar parce qu'il ya des
changements à dar deux fois par année
oui absolument plus bas à l'automne on
peut dormir 1 heure de plus ici pour le
lièvre du canada à gaspé